[Applause]
[Music]
here is a quote from Abigail Anthony at
the National Review as per what's going
on at Columbia University right now Pro
Palestinian students at Colombia
University have organized a tuition
strike for the spring 2024 semester over
Israeli apartheid we want our University
to refuse to invest in ethnic cleansing
and genocide abroad we refuse to accept
our University's silencing of student
voices and demanding demanding
decolonization on our campus reads a
document by the students who intend to
announce a tuition strike after a
thousand pledges we refuse to allow our
tuition dollars to fund apartheid the
strike is organized by the Barnard
Columbia abolitionist Collective the
young Democrat socialists of America and
the student worker solidarity
organizations he want us hang out with a
group of people that can't can't get a
boner there you go uh the protesters
demand a referendum for students across
all Columbia University schools on the
issue of divestment from companies
profiting from or otherwise supporting
Israel apartheid and Colombia's academic
ties to Israel the students demand that
Colombia remove Board of Trustees member
Board of trustee members whose personal
Investments Financial commitments
employment or other business relations
entail profit from or support of Israeli
apartheid and further demand a
commitment to annually issuing a
comprehensive list of board of trust
conflicts of interest with Colombia's
Investments what a pathetic group of
actually racist morons and you idiots
good don't put your money into Colombia
look Colombia should fail you all should
fail you all deserve each other it is a
match made in Hell here's a video of
some students at Columbia chanting long
live the intifa note the name of the
building there standing outside you're
going to find this one
funny
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah that was outside the milstein
center wait till they find out what
religion that guy was when they're
taking a poop after that thing I mean
it's all so stupid these are not the
best and the brightest these children
and again I have some degree of sympathy
for them because the algorithms have
broken their brains their families have
failed them all of the academics have
failed them but good don't go to columia
let Colombia burn as I stand I truly I
stand by this statement right now and
forever I will never hire another
college graduate period at my companies
that's
it